football teams are arriving in cameroon
for the start of the african cup of
nations on sunday
fans who want to attend the games must
be vaccinated and show a negative
covid19 test authorities have set up
hundreds of vaccination centers across
several host cities
apart from the fact that vaccinated
people will see the matches they'll be
protected against the complications of
the disease they'll protect their
relatives and their environment povid19
could end if the majority of people are
vaccinated the tournament is being used
as an incentive in the football mad
nation to encourage vaccine skeptics and
youngsters to get vaccinated
it is necessary to be able to have
access to the stadium during the african
cup of nations so this is what pushed us
cameroonians to come here
if all of the cameroonians are
vaccinated it will encourage all of the
rest of the countries that are coming
for the africa cup
cameroon was stripped of hosting the
african cup in 2019 over stadium
construction delays and security threats
in some parts of the country many
countries in africa are experiencing
their fourth wave of coronavirus with
the omicron variant causing an enormous
challenge to cameroon
less than six percent of its 27 million
population is fully vaccinated while
many simply don't want to get the jab
infections continue to disrupt
preparations for the african cup of
nations egypt has cancelled training and
delayed its player's arrival to the
tournament and guinea has had to leave
three players behind after they tested
positive
but cameroon hopes that this vaccination
campaign could be its most successful
yet while promising a safe tournament
al jazeera